what a joy it was just in time for
global Wall Street beach reading Michael
Lewis he's out with flash boys in
paperback with a new sharp and pointed
afterward some but little has changed
since Lewis went after high frequency
traders one thing that has changed as a
consensus view that the easy solution is
simply to delay by an infinitesimal
split second each and every trade I
asked Michael Lewis about slipping into
a trade you called slippage you can call
whatever is the market is that high
forget traders are getting information
about stock market orders and running in
front of them what I X is done is right
is made it make it impossible to do that
on their exchange and so now you can
measure like what what is it caught what
is it costing investors what i hear is
just create the bride consumer delay
just have everybody within this game
delay an infinitesimal amount they would
work and a lot of the problems go away
yeah we're right you're right another
way to do is put everybody in the same
place if they put all these exchanges
and right in exactly the same place that
would eliminate a lot of the opportunity
but but yes if every market took the
responsibility to make itself fair by
eliminating the speed advantages that
they set but the problems go away the
problem is the exchanges sell the speed
to the trader so it's a big source of
revenue for the exchanges so it would be
a collapse of their business model and
to do this